[Música]
supongo que todos tienen un smartphone
como éste de hecho les acabo de mandar a
todos un mensaje hay en este momento más
líneas de móviles que seres humanos
y 40 por ciento de esas links están
atendidas por smartphones y se calcula
que a fin de la década el 2020 van a ser
un 70 por ciento y así en un avance
exponencial tanto ustedes como yo
tenemos un linaje genético que se
remonta hasta cuatro mil millones de
años atrás cuando aparece la vida en la
tierra con esta célula llamada luca de
la cual descendemos todos ahora bien
este pequeño aparatito también tiene un
linaje no es en este caso biológico sino
que es un linaje tecnológico o sea tiene
un árbol tecnológico entonces sus padres
son el teléfono y el ordenador y podemos
seguir la cadena con el transistor la
válvula de vacío el telégrafo podemos
pasar por la revolución industrial hasta
llegar unos miles años de atrás al ábaco
y si seguimos más atrás al hacha del
neolítico todo eso está en el linaje
y ya que hablamos del hacha leonístico
que podría ser la primera herramienta se
ha descubierto tres millones y medio
años atrás
herramientas talladas en ya no
corresponden al género hongo las
definiciones enciclopédicas de la
tecnología dicen que la tecnología es la
acción o la actividad del ser humano
para crear herramientas con un fin
determinado entonces me parece que eso
es como decir que el sol gira alrededor
de la tierra
porque podemos ver que hay una cantidad
de animales que antes que nosotros o
simultáneamente nosotros utilizan
tecnologías utilizan algún tipo de
artilugio para satisfacer hasta alguna
necesidad pues vamos a ver un caso muy
simpático
y esto los cuernos se divierten haciendo
la sunat snowboard
alguien me dirá que esa tecnología es
muy primitiva no puede nunca llegarse a
la tecnología que ha hecho el hombre con
esto pues bueno vamos a ver un poco más
en detalle eso vamos a ir miles de
millones de años atrás y vamos a ver
esta bacteria que tiene un flagelo que
le impulsa y tiene un motor proteico
hecho de proteínas el mejor motor que se
ha podido conocer en toda la historia
funciona
a una de 10.001 evaluaciones por minuto
y se detiene en un cuarto de vuelta
ese motor es muy superior a esto es un
motor de medidas nanométricas que apenas
se pueden ver hay que llevarlas al
microscopio
y que funciona mucho mejor que esto a
quien que no se queda sin batería que no
se queda sin cobertura bueno eso
funciona siempre quisiera
dar mi idea de lo que es la tecnología
realmente la tecnología es un imperativo
evolutivo es la herramienta que tiene la
naturaleza para evolucionar para crear
complejidad y tal es así que nos ha
hecho a nosotros que nosotros hagamos
tecnología ella nos ha hecho a nosotros
entonces esto requiere una mirada más
humilde sobre nuestra condición de
creadores de tecnología esto requiere
también una mirada sobre lo que es lo
natural
me pregunto y le pregunto
es natural un robot es natural un
ordenador y le digo que sí porque
nosotros hemos creado un robot el
ordenador que nosotros somos seres
naturales
y hemos utilizado las leyes de la
naturaleza para crearlo
en fin podemos decir que es un hecho
artificial porque lo creó el hombre pero
en el fondo es un hecho natural y eso
creo que tiene un componente de humildad
hacia lo que es la naturaleza en lo que
es la tecnología una humildad que
también nos tiene que hacer ver la
condición incoherente que tienen algunas
personas incluido yo
para jugar ciertas cuestiones de la
tecnología el otro día apareció en
facebook
un post que hablaba sobre el impacto de
los clics en el cambio climático faltaba
que pusiera darle al me gusta
como dije antes la tecnología es un
imperativo evolutivo en un proceso
azaroso
hace
50 años alguien está inventando la
pantalla táctil
pero esa persona que estaba en esa labor
no estamos pensando en un smartphone
como einstein cuando decía sus teorías
no estaba pensando en hiroshima y
nagasaki como nuestros tatarabuelos
cuando hacían el amor no estaban
pensando en nosotros
la tecnología tiene un aspecto que
nosotros tenemos que entender para poder
surfear la de alguna manera para poder
entrar en eso en su juego evolutivo y
ganarlo junto con ellas porque al final
nosotros estamos asociados
intrínsecamente a ella somos tecnología
y la tecnología nos está llevando a un
estadio que no podemos reconocer aún
pero que tenemos que empezar a aceptar y
a valorar
creo que lo importante aquí es cuál es
nuestro deseo
cuál es el deseo que sostenemos con
respecto a la tecnología y lo más
importante para mí para mi deseo es lo
que yo creo que la tecnología me va a
dar yo creo que la tecnología
me va a dar la hiper inteligencia y para
mí la hiper inteligencia conlleva la
bondad
pero esto es otro tema de la charla
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]